fox news right now a senior  administration official confirms to fox  news that the national security adviser  that man right there robert o'brien  has now tested positive for coronavirus  the official says that he contracted the  virus outside  of the white house o'brien recently  traveled to france to meet with  president macron  and he was also at a recent family  gathering not saying  either one of those is where he  contracted it but we have now learned  that the national security adviser  robert o'brien has tested positive for  coronavirus  we do not yet know exactly what symptoms  he's having  or his condition when we get that we  will bring it to you  on america's newsroom